hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game you guys requested as soon as
it finished it is magnus carlsen versus
shakhir mahmudara from the blitz section
of the super united tournament currently
being played in zagreb in croatia and
euron fun for rest won the rapid section
now we have two more days of blitz and
then uh the the joint um
uh
uh points accumulated will uh result in
a winner of the tournament so now let's
check it out it's it's a really wild
game and uh to make things worse uh they
repeat the game they already played in
norway chess but um
it still doesn't help
one of the players you know survive for
very long so it's basically a miniature
uh you guys will love it uh let's check
it out magnus has the white pieces and
he opens with knight to f3 he goes for
the retti opening uh d5 by momodaro g3
g6 bishop to g2 and bishop to g7 the
so-called double double fiance variation
of the king's indian attack d4 and
knight to f6 so both players just nicely
developing castles castle c4 and c6 uh
transposing into the neo groomfield line
the the classical one knights to c3 and
now d captures on c4
accepting this pawn which of course
means that magnus will now grab the full
center so pawn to e4 and now in the game
that i've mentioned from norway chess
that uh magnus one um played bishop the
g4 but here mahmoud improves uh by
playing the top move recommended by the
engine and that is pawn to b5 if anyone
is interested bishop to g4
is the second move recommended by the
engine so probably why momodaro decided
to surprise magnus a little bit in
norwegians but here he goes for the main
line of this line uh queen to e2 by
magnus um uh in the now bishop to a6 we
have pawn to a3 and now uh we have
bishop
b7 just uh just putting the bishop back
now it's a very interesting move because
uh bishop b7
is a new move bishop to c8 is a known
one queen to c8 is a known move and also
there is an e6 move from a very nice
game played in 2020 between paraben and
boris girlfriend that girlfriend won
very nicely but here after bishop to b7
we have a completely new game
so let's see how magnus tackles this uh
new position he just advances the pawn
in the center grabs more space knights
to d5 and now he just pushes e6 and here
is where things start to go very very
wrong for uh for mamidyarov uh the only
move that sort of uh keeps equality is
pawn to f5 well also maybe pawn to f6
pawn to f5 is better uh but here my vr
played bishop to c8 and now the position
is uh well it is just lost uh so here my
uh magnus plays knights to g5 now
putting more pressure on this f7 pawn
and you can't really capture this if you
capture this uh just knight captures an
e6 and now if bishop captures of course
now you get queen captures on e6 and
your entire position just falls apart uh
king has to move knight captures and e5
phone captures bishop captures and uh
well you resign here there's no saving
this rook so after knight to g5 majora
tries f6 now seems that uh you know it
should work knight to f7 by magnus
attacking the queen and now uh you could
go for queen to b6 but momodaro first
goes for a night trade now if a knight
captures queen then knight captures
queen with check uh sorry about the
weird arrows uh and now of course b
captures uh b captures on c3 and now
queen to e8 getting the queen out of
harm's way now preparing bishop captures
on e6 and then after the queen captures
we can uh capture the knight on f7 but
magnus says not a problem i i'm not
really interested in that magnus
immediately plays a4 yeah he of course
knows uh everything about this position
and the the bind on this diagonal is
just too great to
recover from bishop captures an e6 is
played but now just knights the h6 with
check
bishop captures an h6 queen captures an
h6 with check and e6 would check king g7
and now bishop captures an h6 uh getting
mamdarov's king all the way to h6 and
you don't have to worry about trying to
checkmate the black king there's really
no good way to do it but just a captures
on b5 and there's no move for mamadara
now you can't capture it it would be a
clean rook
so here we have pawn to a5 but it
doesn't matter just b captures in c6
magnus now gets a beautiful pass pawn on
c6 rook to a7 and now even pawn to d5
beautiful stuff preparing queen e3 check
to pick up the rook on a7 so here kinked
back to g7 and now queen e3 going after
the rook rook the c7 and now magnus just
plays rook captures on a5 and there is
no saving this uh mamadirov could very
well resign here but of course he wants
to survive as long as possible queen to
d8 we have queen to f4 and now rook
captures on c6 you don't have a move
here so emma medyarov has has to try
something
real captures on c6 is played now he's
threatening also to pick up magnus's
rook on a5 but just d captures in c6 we
have queen captures on a5 and now rook
to b1 putting pressure on the knight
here with both queen and the rook so
knight to a6 and now rook to b7 uh
preparing rook captures on e7 queen to
c5 defending and now queen to e4
preparing queen to e6 and bishop to d5
and then it's just over uh so here rook
f7 defending the pawn here but just
queen e6 like we mentioned bishop to d5
is coming and even though mamadarev
stops this uh checkmating attack uh it
doesn't really matter magnus just plays
bishop d5 uh mamijarov trades queens but
it still just resigns here you either
give up the rook and then uh you you you
are you are lost the past pawn is way
too strong or you play what mamidarov
tried rook to f8 rook captures an e7
king to h6 and now pawn to c7 and he was
in this position i move 34 that uh
shakhtar mamiya resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
it is uh hard to describe this uh game
any other way other than effortless uh i
mean uh i hope you guys hope you guys
agree with this but uh i mean uh to make
matters worse like i said he he uh
played the exact same line they already
played in norway chess and now
they are win for the main line as uh you
know okay it's more solid you know
you're not going to just lose the game
out of nowhere but magnus plays this e6
move that i'm probably going to use uh
for my thumbnail
and there just
was no way of saving this it's a blitz
game so of course if you have more time
you will you will find f5 but after
bishop c8 it resigns so really
spectacular showing by magnus uh taking
dom amidaravina in in a miniature like
this
i hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would
like to thank uh wright travis michael
colbert kevin kline ravishing reptile
youtube and omicron for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes uh so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
if you have a game that you think should
be shown to everyone do suggest as there
are so many games being played
thank you and see you soon